Osama and I inna fled their home in
Syria to find safety but instead they
found people smugglers having found
their way to Greece they wanted to seek
asylum in Sweden but the person who
insisted he could help did anything but
a fanatic yawn papa but the seat but no
sir hey la cyanide TV bal ADBA video he
said we have the army but bday a car
mehsana horny I [ __ ] fasala optimism
melody dear dear inhibitors la a song
since the conflict erupted in Syria
three years ago around 2.4 million
people have registered as refugees
Germany has offered to take twenty
thousand Syrians but in the rest of
Europe only 5,000 more have been
accepted at the European Council on
refugees and exiles they're calling on
the EU to act what we are asking a
European leaders is to provide the
refugees with an alternative to put
themselves in the hands of a Smuggler's
the only solution we are actually
providing is world with your life and
see if you can make it and that is not
an option in 2013 emmy peas gave the
green light to the new common European
asylum system which aimed to streamline
asylum applications and detention
conditions across the EU however the
trouble lies in the implementation in
the Member States at the moment we have
many countries you want to pick and
choose how they deal with crisis like
the refugee crisis of Syria the problem
with that is that as a European Union it
means we're not cooperating and burden
sharing the people who suffer are the
Syrians on World Refugee day this friday
over 100 ngos will present a petition
calling on european leaders to allow
safe passage to syrian refugees coming
to europe ensure that those who do make
it are not push back across the borders
and also help reunite families torn
apart by conflict